CLIFF: Welcome, good afternoon.
Today for Talks at Google
we're very thrilled to have two
thought leaders from the
Council on Foreign Relations.
They're here to discuss their
latest book, "By All Means
Necessary: How China's Resource
Quest is Changing the World."
And so the economic
expansion in China
is pretty well documented
in the press and news,
but behind it is
a quest for fuel,
or water, and even
land for farming.
And so this book outlines
the ramifications
behind this massive undertaking.
So we have actually Elizabeth
Economy, the CV star Senior
Fellow and Director
for Asian Studies
at the Council on
Foreign Relations.
She's also Vice Chair of the
World Economic Forum's Global
Agenda Council on
the Future of China,
and she serves on the Board
of the China US Center
for Sustainable development.
So coming in from the
China prospective.
And also we have Michael Levi,
the David M. Rubenstein Senior
Fellow for Energy and in
the Environment at the CFR.
And he works primarily on
energy security and climate
change as well as
nuclear terrorism.
So from arms control
to sustainability,
they're true experts
in their fields.
We'll also have time
for a Q&A at the end.
But for now, please join me
in welcoming them to Google.
Thanks.
ELIZABETH ECONOMY: Thanks.
Thanks very much, Cliff.
It's really a pleasure
for me and Mike
to have the opportunity
to be here at Google
to share with you our research
on our new book "By All Means
Necessary: How china's Resource
Quest is Changing the World."
There were a number of
reasons why Mike and I decided
to undertake this project.
But chief among
them was our sense
that we're in the midst of one
of the great transformative
processes of our time.
Namely, the rise of China.
And yet we have only a
limited understanding
of what that rise means
for the global economy,
for governance, and for
international security.
And so we decided to
look at one of the issues
that we believe is really
at the heart of this rise.
Namely, China's resource quest.
Its effort to secure resources
from outside its borders
in order to fuel
its economic growth.
Certainly there's
been a lot of hype
in the media
surrounding this issue.
China can be either the
savior of the global economy,
or the scourge of good
global governance,
or it's undermining
international security
because of its willingness to do
business anywhere at any time.
But Mike and I decided we wanted
to look behind the headlines
and really explore the
reality of the issues.
And so we looked at four
different sets of commodities.
Oil and gas, water,
land, and minerals.
And we looked throughout
the developing world
in Southeast Asia, and
Africa, Latin America,
and also in resource rich
advanced industrialized
countries like the United
States, Canada, and Australia.
And what we found I think
speaks to sort of six
generally held
assumptions or one
might call them myths
about this resource quest.
And so we're each going
to talk about a couple
of these myths for
about 25 to 30 minutes.
And then we're going
to welcome obviously
your comments and
your questions.
So first, sort of
commonly held assumption--
perhaps the most basic one--
is that China's resource quest
is unprecedented in history.
And on the face of it, if
you look at the numbers,
it is quite striking.
I mean China commands
upwards of 30%, 40%, even 50%
of global supply of zinc,
iron, nickel, coal, lead.
So clearly its impact on
global resource supply demand
is profound.
Yet when we look
back through history,
we find that China is
really simply following
a trajectory that has
occurred time and again.
And in fact that all
rising great powers
have sought resources
outside their borders
to grow their economy.
Going back to
ancient Athens, which
went outside of its borders
to get timber and corn.
Certainly the United
States sought resources
from outside its borders.
And most recently, Japan.
Not many of you
probably will remember,
but perhaps some of you will.
In the early 1970s,
and 1980s, when
there was a lot of concern
about the rise of Japan.
Interestingly, in
the early 1970s,
Japan with about
120 million people
commanded 10% of the
world's oil supply.
And when you look
at China today,
you see that China
with 1.3 billion people
commands not much more than
about 12% of the world's oil
supply.
And of course, that speaks
to market supply and demand
and Mike's going to talk
a lot more about that.
But I think it gives
you some context
to understand that while
China's rise is quite striking,
it's not necessarily
unprecedented.
And it's not an unprecedented
in terms of China's own history
because if you
look back thousands
of years-- in the book
we really just look back
about 700 years to
the Ming dynasty--
you see that many of these sort
of governing traits of China's
resource quest
that we find today
were present 700 years ago.
Sort of a strong
central directive.
Who can go out for
resources, where you can go,
what resources you
should be going out for,
who can profit from
this resource quest.
Many of these things are
sort of deeply rooted
from 700 years ago.
In addition, a sort
of sense within China
of insecurity about
its resources,
particularly when
it comes to grain.
And again we track
this throughout history
up until today when we find that
some aspects of this insecurity
are beginning to change.
Nonetheless, I think overall,
we find in this particular case
that yes, China's rise
and its resource quest
is certainly changing things,
but it's not unprecedented.
A second thing that
we tackle-- a sort
of second myth or
common assumption--
is that Chinese
firms are somehow
advantaged in their
competition against what
Western multinationals-- because
of the very strong engagement
by the Beijing.
And indeed, when you
read the newspaper--
when you open a
newspaper-- you'll
see that President
Xi Jinping may
travel to Africa, or Latin
America, or to Southeast Asia,
and he'll be accompanied by
a dozen ministers, or state
owned enterprise heads,
or representatives
of the major Chinese banks.
And they will propose a sort
of a vast array of trade,
and aid, and investment deals
as they approach each country.
And it can look to
the outside observer
as though she is a conductor of
a very finely tuned orchestra.
With each section playing its
part perfectly and in harmony.
But what Mike and I found
is that much less harmony
and much more
cacophony, in fact.
In many respects this resource
quest is not exactly a proceed
as we might believe
it from the outside.
So for example, the National
Development and Reform
Commission-- which is maybe
the composer of the music.
So it's the one that designs
perhaps the broad plan
for the trade and aid in
investment for a given
country-- may lay this plan out.
But then it's up to the
state owned enterprises
to decide whether or not
they want to participate.
And in many instances
they don't want
to participate because
they see participation
as a money losing
endeavor for them.
And they want to
make money and they
want to compete on the
international stage.
We also found that
in many cases,
Chinese-- particularly in the
mining sector which is largely
not state directed--
Chinese go out on their own
with no direction from Beijing.
So for example, looking back
about a year ago in March,
the [INAUDIBLE] government
told the Chinese,
look we've got these thousands
of Chinese gold miners,
and their here
illegally, and they're
despoiling our environment.
Could you please take
care of this problem.
And Beijing said, well, no.
This is your problem.
We have nothing to do
with all of these miners.
We certainly didn't send
them out or bring them out.
You need to do a
better job of enforcing
your own laws and
your own regulations.
And come July, Ghana rounded
up all of these miners-- close
to 5,000 of them--
and kicked them out.
So this was a black
eye for Beijing.
But they had nothing
to do with this part
of this outward investment
or this resource quest,
yet it reflects
back upon Beijing.
Another aspect of
this disaggregation--
this sort of the lack
of coordination--
is really when you look at what
China proposes for investment
and how much of
that is realized.
So dating back to
about 2007-- if you've
been following for example,
the Chinese investments
in Brazil-- it totals about $70
billion which is substantial.
But then you look at
the realized investment,
and you find out it's
only 30% of that.
And some of that has to do again
with Chinese firms not wanting
to participate in what the
Chinese government structured,
and some of that has to do
with the difficulties of doing
business in Brazil.
And finally, there's the
sense that somehow China's
got it right.
That all these Chinese
companies are out there
making all this money.
And that's something
else that we've found
was actually not the case.
In fact, there's a
recent announcement
by a Chinese mining
official that over 80%
of Chinese mining investment
overseas is not profitable.
So when we're reading
the newspapers, when
we're seeing what's
going on with President
Xi and these gigantic
deals for investment,
we've discovered that certainly
some of this is taking place.
But it's really much
less than meets the eye.
MICHAEL LEVI: Why
don't I pick up there
and talk a little
bit about economics.
First though, let me
add my thanks to you
all for hosting me.
It's the first time given a talk
with a pool table behind me.
It's pretty exciting.
I want to talk
first about what's
happened with the
prices of commodities.
Because that's the way we feel.
China's resource quest,
most directly-- or at least
it's the way we think we feel
China's resource requests
most directly-- If you look
out over the last decade,
we've seen a far higher prices
for oil, for gas, for minerals.
And the story is not just
that China has driven this.
But that China will continue
to drive us into the future.
That we've only seen the
tip of what's to come
and we'll continually see
ever rising resource prices.
One of the great
things about being
able to look at China's rise
through this resource quest
though is that this isn't just
speculation about the future.
We have a track record.
We can dig in and
ask what have we seen
and why has it happened.
And when we dig in on these
different commodities,
we learn some things that
put a lot more nuance
into the picture.
So yes, without
China, we would not
have seen these enormous rises.
Particularly for oil,
for iron, or for copper
that we saw over
the last decade.
But the simple story ends there.
And let me just flag
a couple pieces that
strike me as a very interesting.
If you look at
forecaster's projections
for oil prices
around the year 2000.
They basically said we
will have $20 oil forever.
The really worried ones
said we will have $30 oil.
But China's rise isn't
what they got wrong.
If you look across
these projections,
you find that they
were mostly on target
when it came to rising
Chinese demand for oil.
What they got wrong
was they assumed
that the rest of the
world would expand
oil production to respond.
Essentially, as a friendly
gesture to keep prices low.
That Saudi Arabia, and
Iran, and Kuwait, and others
would play along and keep
prices low for everyone
by responding to China's rise.
What happened in reality,
Chinese consumption grew,
the supply didn't
respond in this case--
probably for political
reasons-- and crisis
had to rise because someone else
had to consume less in order
to make the pieces add up.
Who end up consuming less?
Mostly the developed countries.
So here China is
an essential piece
of the puzzle in
understanding why prices rose,
but you can't
understand what happened
without looking at how
the other parts fit in.
You have a similar story
on the iron ore front.
When you look at the rise
of China as a consumer,
it's enormous.
But in principle,
global iron ore supplies
can rise to catch up.
The issue there is that
it takes a long time.
And that's the case for a lot
of investment other resources,
too.
You can't simply turn
on the tap overnight.
It takes a long time to plan
new mines, to execute them,
to get political buy-in
the countries where
those are being developed.
And in the interim, prices
can go through the roof.
And that's what we've seen in
that case, a lag in the ability
of the big suppliers
to catch up.
There's another piece that's
worth paying attention to.
Because even though
we've seen the price
rises in a lot of places, we
haven't seen them everywhere.
So when you look at aluminum for
example, the price of aluminum
has not gone up
nearly as much as it
has for some of these
other resources.
Why?
Because the market was
already on the upswing.
There was already a lot of
anticipated growth in demand.
Not just from
developing countries,
but developed
countries for things
like lighter frames
for automobiles
to become more efficient
and pieces like that.
You also saw the market--
this particular market-- more
flexible and more
easily able to respond.
And on the food front,
you saw big price rises,
but if you drill down there
are a host of other drivers.
A lot of other developing
countries with rapidly growing
food demand, some
severe droughts
that cut into supply, and on
top of that political reactions
to some of those developments
that intensified the price
impacts.
When we look out at the
future, all of those dynamics
need to come into play.
What we're seeing in particular
is the system start to respond.
Both outside of China
and inside of it.
We've seen a lot more effort
to become more efficient
in our use of resources.
In general, slowing
the growth of demand.
Not reversing it,
but slowing it.
We've seen the
supply side respond.
So if you look in oil
and gas for example,
enormous transformations
in technology
that have allowed a
lot more production.
Not at the kinds
of $20 prices we
saw or expected a decade
ago, but without having
to go from 20 to 100 and then
to 200 and 300 and so on.
So the system is
starting to respond.
And again I'd emphasize
particularly in China,
not only through
adoption of technology,
but through an effort to shift
the sources of Chinese growth,
to rebalance the economy
happening in fits and starts.
Certainly not accomplished yet
but responses across the board
that I think limit
the big potential
for really large
increases in resource
prices due to China
in the future.
We're not going back
to the year 2000,
but we're probably not going
to repeat the last decade
all over again either.
So that's one side of
the economics picture.
What's the price?
The other side is in
some ways a deeper--
and if you look at a decade
ago-- more troubling.
And that's this question of
whether markets will continue
to dominate the way we allocate
resources the way we trade.
The way we decide who gets
what around the world.
And the reason that
markets are important
is because they let you take
politics out of the equation.
So is it bad to pay more
for oil or for ores?
Sure.
It's a lot worse to have
to fight wars over them.
If you are allocating
things politically.
And a decade ago, that's what
the big claims about China
were.
China is going to take us away
from a market-based system
which has tended to prevail
and toward a political system--
a mercantilist system-- where
you use at best politics
and at worst force to
allocate the world's
supply of resources.
This is the sort of world that
developed before World War II
and we know that
didn't end well.
So what's the decade
of experience tell us?
What it tells us is
that not only has China
been remarkably
unsuccessful in transforming
the world to a different
system, it actually-- and not
on purpose-- but in some
cases, has actually moved it
to a more flexible, more
market-based, less political
system than it was in before.
Let me tell you a
few reasons why.
But let me start by
flagging the exceptions.
The big exception the
stands out is rare earths.
That's because China has a
dominant market position.
95% of global rare
earth production.
Starting to shift gradually,
but those responses are slow.
So when China controls the vast
majority of what's out there,
it's able to make the
market work differently.
But in most cases, China doesn't
control the vast majority
of what's out there.
There are other
places where it looks
like China is
controlling everything,
but that's mostly superficial.
So do you see a huge volume
of iron ore being produced
in mines that China has
relationships with and sent
back to China?
Yes.
But that's not
necessarily so exciting.
You don't need to
depart from markets
to have a lot of copper or
iron sent back to China.
All you need is the fact that
China is a dominant consumer
of these resources
around the world.
Even if others were
producing them,
they would be making
their way back to China.
In the iron ore piece, most
of the world's iron ore market
is structured around
vertically integrated firms.
You own the mine upstream,
you produce, you send it
to your steel mills downstream.
And Chinese companies
in that sense
are no different from
how others have behaved.
On the oil front-- where I
think most of the controversy
has come-- people
worried about China
buying equity oil-- investing
in oil around the world--
and then shipping it back home.
In some sense, taking it
away from the global market.
What you find out when
you drill down on this
is that the bulk
of Chinese equity
oil-- the bulk of
Chinese produced
oil-- is not shipped
back to China.
It's shipped on to
the global market.
And it's not shipped to China's
favorite political partners.
There's a guy in
London or New York
that the Chinese company
hires, and they trade it
just like they do any
other source of oil
to the highest bidder.
There are even places in China's
periphery in Central Asia that
have pipelines going
straight into China.
They will sell it into other
pipelines going elsewhere
if that's where the profits lie.
Let me give you one last
piece where China in some ways
accidentally encouraged
the creation of a market,
and that's iron ore.
I'll tell you in the
list of different things
that surprised me when we
were writing this book.
The biggest is
that I've ended up
finding iron ore
really interesting.
I never really anticipated that.
It turns out-- I know
you'll be shocked--
iron ore is a kind of
an interesting world.
Until a few years ago, there
were three big companies
that controlled most of the
world's iron ore markets.
They sat down with the
biggest buyer in Japan,
they had a little
negotiation among them,
they picked a price,
and then everyone
had to agree to use that price
for the entire next year.
That's not the
kind of marketplace
we're used to using.
China, when it
came on the scene,
said, this is a good system.
We can be that guy in the
room instead of the Japanese.
We'll get an even
better deal out of them,
and this will work
out well for us.
What happened
though, was you had--
and this goes to Liz's point.
It's not all about
the state-- you
had huge numbers of small steel
mills scattered around China
all trying to do
their own thing.
They didn't want
to play that game.
They went out, whether
the state like it or not,
and bought their iron
ore at whatever price
they could get it at.
And over time, that built
up into a large market.
And when the world went through
the financial crisis in 2008,
and there was an enormous amount
of turmoil in the markets,
people started to say, we don't
like this political negotiating
system.
We don't like this every
year changing thing.
They said, well,
there's a market.
It's being developed.
Not on purpose, but
by accident by all
of these entrepreneurial
Chinese firms.
And they shifted to that.
And today-- a few
years later-- you
have a fundamentally
transformed market,
a lot less political power
involved, a lot more open
trade.
The kind of thing that's
good for economies
but also good for
international security.
ELIZABETH ECONOMY: So if prices
are one of the flash points
and sort of the
media headlines when
it comes to China's
quest for resources,
the other is probably
China's impact
on the ground in the countries
where it's doing investing.
So what is China doing in terms
of the environment, and labor,
and just good governance,
corruption, and transparency?
So what we've taken away from
actually pretty detailed set
of cases and research
studies on this front,
is that the best way to
understand China's impact
abroad, is really
to look at what
China's doing on the home front.
So for example, if
we can look at China
today and the pollution
catastrophe that it's facing.
In part, that's because
a lot of Chinese firms
don't undertake environmental
impact assessments
and they're not enforced.
Well you know what.
When Chinese firms go to
Zambia, oftentimes they also
don't undertake environmental
impact assessments.
So China tends to do abroad
what it's doing at home.
On the labor front, there
were a number of issues
that we discovered that were
somewhat problematic in terms
of Chinese investment.
Whether we're looking at
Papua New Guinea or Peru,
miners there tended to complain
that Chinese mining practices
were sort of bottom
of the barrel when
it comes to labor and safety.
In some cases, it
was absolutely true.
In most cases, it was true.
But in some cases, there
are also other Western firms
that were bottom of
the barrel as well.
But by and large you did
not find Chinese firms
who were acting to raise
labor and safety practices.
So basically, on the pay
front and on the safety front,
Chinese firms were below par.
This is not surprising.
That mining industry in China
is one of the most dangerous
in the world.
More mine fatalities per
capita than anywhere else
in the world.
So again, not surprising to
find that when Chinese mining
companies go abroad, they're
bringing those same practices.
In terms of governance and
transparency in corruption,
one of the interesting trips
that I took was to Brazil.
And I met with a
lot of officials
there who were dealing
with a vast number
of Chinese delegations.
Who were going to Brazil
to invest in land.
They wanted to buy land-- which
eventually became impossible
for a set of different
reasons but they
wanted to buy land--
mostly to grow soybeans.
And the Brazilian officials
said when these delegations come
here, they basically think
that we officials can simply
sign away the land.
They come to us and say OK,
we want to do this deal.
Just sign on the dotted line.
But of course, that's
not the way things work.
But in China, that
is the way it works.
Land deals are done
between local officials
and local businesses in the
back room illegally expropriated
land.
And that's why illegal
land expropriation
is one of the largest
sources of social unrest--
of the 180,000 or more protests
now that China faces annually.
So again, what we see
on the home front,
is largely what we see
China doing abroad.
But the story doesn't end there.
And it can have a much
more positive ending.
And that's something
we also discovered
in the course of our research
which is to the extent
now that China is
beginning to develop better
corporate social
responsibility practices.
It's going to be
exporting those as well.
There's pressure coming from
Beijing itself on Chinese firms
to do a better job.
So they're putting in place
laws and regulations that
say, if you don't undertake
an environmental impact
assessment in Zambia,
you're not going
to get any money from
China [INAUDIBLE] Bank.
Or you can't go public on
the Shenzhen stock exchange
if you have some sort of
environmental black mark
against your firm.
So they're starting to
put in some regulations
and strictures.
I would say spottily enforced,
just as they are spottily
enforced on the home front.
But nonetheless,
this is the trend
within the Chinese
government is to begin
to hold these Chinese
firms to a higher standard.
We also find the Chinese
firms themselves often
want to do a better job.
They want to compete against
Western multinationals.
They want to be
world-class companies.
And they learn from each other.
So in Peru, for example,
we saw that early entrance
into the mining industry--
early Chinese entrance-- really
work bottom of the barrel.
And for 10 or more
decades, these firms
continue to have
protests against them
from Peruvian miners and local
people-- local communities.
But gradually, later
Chinese entrance-- later
Chinese mining
firms have learned.
They hire Western CEOs, or
they hire local Peruvians
to help with
community relations,
they hire outside firms
to do environmental impact
assessments-- real environmental
and social impact assessments.
So again, beginning to transform
the way that they do business
as a result of wanting
themselves to be world class
competitors.
And I think it's
important to remember
that it takes two to tango.
So we found very different
Chinese experiences
depending on where they
were doing business.
So stronger state capacity
in a resource rich country
generally meant that
you had a better
result in Chinese investment.
So we found in countries like
Mongolia, for example, putting
in place laws that
said look, we're
worried about the Chinese
exporting their labor.
That's also a very
big concern when
China comes calling
primarily for infrastructure,
not so much for resource
quest, but a lot
of infrastructure development
surrounds resource development.
So the Mongolians said
every Chinese miner
you have to hire nine
Mongolian miners.
And now, maybe this is
not so strongly enforced,
but the idea is there.
There's an awareness of how they
want to negotiate and navigate
with the Chinese government.
So that kind of
state capacity maybe
missing in a
country like Zambia,
for example, and
therefore Zambia
will suffer more in terms of
a Chinese investment on sort
of labor, environmental front.
And finally, I think probably
the newest development
that we've seen is the
beginning of grassroots pressure
within China on Chinese
firms to do a better job.
Of course, there's been
that for a few decades
now when it comes to domestic
environmental issues in China.
But we're just beginning to see
Chinese domestic environmental
NGOs trying to hold
Chinese firms to count
when they go abroad.
So for example, a
Chinese NGO that
goes to Burma/Myanmar
in interviews
spends two weeks
traveling around talking
to local communities there
and then comes back and tells
the Chinese firms you
need to do a better job.
You need to engage
with local communities.
It's not enough simply to strike
a deal with the local officials
because you're losing
out on the best deals.
You are losing out because
you have no public support.
So I think there are
all these pressures now
that are being exerted on
Chinese firms-- some of them
internal to the firms themselves
but many others coming
from outside-- that I think
are propelling a Chinese firm
behavior-- sort of general
corporate social responsibility
practices-- in the
right direction.
It's too early frankly
to say that China
has turned the corner
in this regard.
But I think the trend line is
moving in a positive direction.
MICHAEL LEVI: You've heard
so many things about Zambia
and the environment that I have
to give one little anecdote.
When I was in Zambia
a couple years ago
doing research for
this book, I spoke
with someone who told me
about a company that actually
had submitted its environmental
impact assessment.
It was in Chinese.
It was approved despite the
fact that no one in the Zambian
government spoke Chinese.
I don't know maybe they put
it through a Google Translate.
I'm suspicious.
But this is the
sort of thing that
happens when your capacity
isn't up to scratch.
I want to talk about a last
myth-- or misunderstanding--
that surrounds China's
impact on global security
and international politics.
It's pretty easy to see
China's resource quest
as fundamentally changing
political relationships,
deeply undermining global
security, inflating bad guys,
change relationships leading
to military confrontation.
You certainly see the image
of China's state presence
in a lot of resource
rich countries.
When I was doing research on
the book I went to Mozambique.
It is not difficult
to figure out
that China has a strong
political relationship
with Mozambique because the roof
the Mozambique Foreign ministry
is a pagoda style roof.
And the Chinese company
that built it decided that
would be a really nice touch to
put on the Mozambique Foreign
Ministry.
This is not the embassy.
This is Mozambique's
own foreign ministry.
And it's true that as you
look around the world,
you see places where China
has resource investments
and is distorting the way the
world deals with its problems.
China certainly has
not bent over backward
to be helpful on Iran.
Less because imports--
well from their end more
because it wants to
preserve opportunities
as an investor in
Iranian oil and gas.
You see in Sudan-- one
of the earliest places
where China invested in
resources-- the Chinese have
tried at least to weaken
the Security Council
response during the last
decade to internal conflict.
On the military front,
there is undoubtedly
a desire within pieces
of the Chinese military
and senior political leadership
to play more of a direct role
in providing security for
its own resource flows.
To have a stronger Navy,
to have a military that's
able to operate more
effectively abroad.
And when you add
more and more strong
militaries to a small
area, you inevitably
raise the risks of conflict.
When you drill down these
pieces though, what you find
is that there are severe
limitations-- at least
for the time being--
to Chinese leverage.
And let me flag
a couple examples
I think drive this home.
The first is in Iran.
There was a big fear
that as Western companies
tried to gain leverage over
the Iranian nuclear program
by telling their oil and gas
companies that they couldn't
invest, that China would
just come in and take over
the leases, pump
out the oil or gas,
and make this essentially
painless for the Iranians.
And what happened?
Two really striking
things happened.
First is that, it turned
out that for a lot
of the developments
in Iran, China either
didn't have the technical
capacity by itself--
so actually, if you
look around the world,
China's often partnering
with Western companies.
Not operating alone.
So they couldn't step
in because of that.
There were other
technical limits
where the Chinese had 90%
of the pieces they needed
to do a development, but there
were some high tech or elements
that required specialized
materials that they could only
get from a European supplier.
And that European
supplier was saying
we're not allowed to play
ball with you on this front.
So they weren't actually able
to step in as effectively
and fill that gap.
At the same time that
they weren't able to,
they were being
deterred from doing it.
So you had one instance
where Chinese companies
we're looking at two
sorts of possibilities.
One was stepping in
for some Western firms
that were moving out of Iran.
The other was investing
more in the United States.
There's been a lot of Chinese
activity in the last few years
doing joint ventures in
American all gas production.
And they got a subtle--
not a big broadcast,
but subtle-- message that they
might have to make a choice.
That if they invested
more in Iran,
people here might be
politically concerned
about their own
investments here.
And ultimately, the
predominant choice
was to invest in
the United States
rather than to invest in Iran.
A second thing that
we see is that China
may want to be hands-off
to essentially stay out
of internal politics in
countries where gets involved.
But sometimes it
doesn't have the choice.
And its found
increasingly, for example,
in Sudan and South
Sudan that it may
want to stay out of
what's happening there.
But it's investments
are worthless when
conflict means that
it can't produce.
And in particular,
when conflict means
that it can't operate the
pipelines to get the oil
it's producing out.
And so China may intend to have
a we don't interfere policy,
but that may not be tenable.
And it's learning
that as it goes
through some of its
engagements around the world.
Last front worth
paying attention to
is this military front.
The United States wouldn't
feel particularly comfortable
if the Chinese military was the
one responsible for security
of all the resources that
come back to this country.
If we were in a situation where
we depended on China for all
that security, we
would be agitating
to build up our own
military and provide
that security for ourselves.
That's what China's doing.
China relies on
the United States
for security in the Middle East.
It relies on the United
States for security
much closer to home.
And a relies on
the United States
to not decide to cut off
its own access to resources.
So if you're China, you want
to build up the capacity
to provide some of the
security for sea lanes
that critical resources
travel through for yourself.
The problem is there
a lot of other things
are the Chinese
military wants to do.
China has one aircraft
carrier at this point.
So even if right now it wanted
to provide all the security--
to kick out the
United States, do it
for itself-- it
wouldn't be able to.
And as we move out
into the future
and China does build
up a greater capacity,
it will be looking at a host of
different ways it can use it.
Will it want to use it
for defense for capacity
in case of a
conflict over Taiwan?
Will it want to use
it in the sea lanes
close to home where it's
most capable of operating?
Those are the places
where resources
will get pulled to
in the short run.
Not sending ships off
to the Strait of Hormuz
to replace the United States
and others in the middle east.
I want to move pretty quickly
to questions and answers,
but let me quickly
recap three themes that
help us at least organize how
we think about China's resource
quest.
Just run through a lot of
what we've been talking about.
The first is that to understand
what China does abroad,
you have to really look at
how China behaves and operates
at home.
Whether it's-- like Liz said--
how they do environmental
impact assessments,
or handle labor,
or whether it's this broader
question of state control
versus limited administrative
capacity that allows companies
to often do their own thing.
That same scene that prevails
at home prevails abroad.
There are other
influences abroad,
but that's a critical
starting point.
The second is that regardless
of whether the Chinese state is
controlling or is not, or
whether it's intentions are
nefarious or not, that the
China is an enormous and growing
economy means that what
it does consequential.
There's a habit of saying
if China's well intentioned,
there is no problem.
And if China is ill
intentioned, there is.
Intentions aren't the only
thing that matter here.
China has consequences
whether it's
for markets, or for security,
or for prices in economies
regardless of what
its intentions are.
The third piece I
drive home as sort
of the counterpart of the first.
Yes, China brings its own
approach to the world.
Yes, China has different
ways of doing things.
But the global system
is pretty resilient.
It responds in some strong ways.
When China tried to put
quotas on rarest materials,
those got struck
down in the WTO.
Still a work in progress, but
the system started to respond.
When China has pushed
prices up, the system
has responded by
encouraging more production,
cutting consumption, and
driving technology development.
When China has tried to change
the way politics and economics
mix in some of the
countries where it invest,
it hasn't been able to
sustain that all the time.
And as China has gained exposure
to the rest of the world,
is it's learned things.
It's learn ways to do things
better that are good for itself
but also good for the
rest of the world.
And I think we'll
continue to see
this interplay between
China bringing something
new to the world, and the
world adapting and influencing
China itself in
pretty strong ways
not just over the next
few years but really
over the next few decades
as China's rise continues.
Thank you all for
your attention.
AUDIENCE: One of the myths
I have at least about China
that I'm curious to
hear you talk about
is I often get the impression
that parts of China
are desperately
poor and desperately
resource constrained.
And so to some extent
China has to do
what it's trying
to do to import all
these resources from
outside of the country.
Because not only do
they want to grow,
but they have to figure out
how to feed people and raise
these desperately poor
people out of poverty.
Which is perhaps
different than-- certainly
different than what the US
would have been in a situation.
Probably even different than
what Japan and Britain, who
were much more resource
constrained were.
And I was wondering you
can talk a little bit
about to what extent are
they doing what they're
doing because they feel like to
have to lift their society up
versus just seeking
to grow their economy?
ELIZABETH ECONOMY: Let
me say a couple of words
and maybe Mike
wants to chime in.
I think one of the commodities
we looked was water issues.
And I think there's probably
no greater concern in China.
You think air
pollution as a problem.
Actually, the water
scarcity issue
is a much bigger problem
for China and particularly
in the north and the
west of the country.
And so we looked at
how China is actually
water rich but because
of its pollution
and because of it's
degradation of its resources.
Half of the 50,000 river in
China have simply dried up
and disappeared over
the past few decades.
It's being forced to undertake
major river diversions.
It seeks to control
the water resources
that flow into places
like Kazakhstan,
or India, or down
into the Mekong.
And so it encounters some
battles with these countries
because, in fact, they
need this water as well
to grow their own economies.
But China is not interested
in negotiating in part
because this water
still very desperately
needed by China itself.
When you're asking whether
China's seeking resources
to grow its economy or to
lift another 100 to 200
million people out of poverty,
they're kind of the same thing.
Because that has
always been the mission
of the Chinese government.
To continue to lift
hundreds of millions
of people out of
poverty as they have
done over the past
several decades.
One of the things
that Mike raised
was this issue of
rebalancing the economy
and the urbanization
processes taking place.
So moving a lot of those
desperately poor people--
migrant workers-- into cities.
That's how they
believe they're going
to develop a middle class.
While that may have some
positive ramifications
for China's resource
quest, the truth
is that urban residents
use four times the energy
and three times the water
that rural residents do.
So some of that
rebalancing of the economy
could actually prove
even more challenging
for China's resource quest.
So I think absolutely they're
out there seeking resources
to continue to fuel the
excellent lifestyles
of the urban residents
on the coastal China.
But they're also
seeking those resources
to lift up those other 200
to 300 million people who
are not living the coastal life.
MICHAEL LEVI: Just
to build on that.
I think it's both.
When you to import a lot of
iron ore and use a lot of energy
in order to produce
steel to build up cities
so that you can bring people in
and lift them out of poverty,
that's certainly what
you're talking about.
When you do it to ship that
steal to somewhere else
and sell it, these are
capital intensive, not
labor intensive businesses.
This does not bring a lot
of people out of poverty.
That's not to say
that it's good or bad.
But different pieces
of the resource dynamic
can be more or less about
poverty alleviation,
broad-based growth
versus return to the top.
I think it's also worth
separating the trade
piece from the others.
The drive for trade, the
drive to have resources
to fuel growth and to fuel
a move into the middle class
is certainly there.
The investment imperative
abroad I think is different.
It's more similar
to what you saw
in Japan, what you saw in
the United States, what
you saw in Britain.
Partly driven by the fact
that you have big companies
with the capacity to invest.
What the big companies with
the capacity and opportunity
to invest do?
They typically invest.
And so not a shock
the Chinese companies
are doing that as well.
On top of that, to the extent
that they're vertically
integrated-- so they have
these responsibilities
downstream, whether it's in
refineries or steel mills--
they often want some
security of supply
even if they're not
physically moving
it, at least some
financial security
through upstream ownership.
And so you see some
of that happening.
So I think it depends on
the particular dynamic
that you're thinking about.
How much you tie that to the
rise of people out of poverty
into middle class
and how much this
is about making
rich people richer.
AUDIENCE: So I actually
have a question.
I did my thesis actually
on Chinese carbon emissions
and US GDP.
So kind of focusing on the
Chinese resource consumption
and trade piece on all these
emissions embodied in trade.
Could you just
speak a bit on how
we're putting the onus on China
even though we're probably
indirectly consuming a lot
in driving these prices?
AUDIENCE: So it depends on which
research you're talking about.
So for people here who didn't
do their thesis on this issue,
the way we typically count
emissions and resource
consumption is where
the smoke stack is
or where the resource
gets transformed.
So if I have a factory in
China producing widgets
for some of the United
States, it's their emissions.
Is their energy consumption
even those my widget.
And you get into a
lot of discussions
about responsibility.
Particularly, in
the climate space
because the climate
space immediately
runs you into a discussion
of responsibility.
The problem there--
and certainly a lot
of our emissions
reductions-- not
all them but a substantial part
of our missions reductions--
have come from
offshore manufacturing
to places like China.
The problem there is that the
way to take responsibility
for that is for us to say
well we will pay a fee.
Just like we might want to
charge a fee on US emissions,
we'll pay a fee on
activities, on products
that ultimately come
from Chinese emissions.
Politically, the
Chinese hate that.
So they like the
responsibility idea.
They hate the solution to it.
And in the practical
world, it's the solution
that ends up having
the consequences.
So that's a tricky
piece to navigate.
I think on the broader
resource question, look,
we all feel the consequences.
I don't think it's
particularly useful, especially
when you're talking about who's
contributing to price rises
to have it as a sort of blame
game at least at a moral level.
I do think it's
useful to understand
what drives these
changes and that
gets back to this previous one.
Most Chinese steel production
is driven by demand
from the Chinese
domestic economy.
That is not about export
with United States
except in a second
order kind of way.
You need cities in order to
have people working and people
working in order to ship things.
But some of it is sent
to the United States.
And trying to differentiate
between these pieces is useful.
There's a paper-- a guy who I
like a lot at Princeton who's
a mechanical engineer but also
studies climate policy issues
together with a couple folks.
I'm trying to remember
which California university,
but one of them is doing--
trying differentiate
between these pieces.
How do you go a level beyond
is it ours or is it theirs.
And think about which resource
consumption, which emissions
are for building up
the domestic economy
and which are really just
to send it back to us.
CLIFF: Thank you all for
speaking with us today
and we will have time to
sign books at the end.
Thank you.